produced with exclusive support from
Illumina if you change the notes of
Beethoven you'd probably get a strange
reaction we don't have to change a music
school to change how its expressed
and it's the same in our genes you don't
have to change the DNA itself to change
how genes are expressed almost every
cell in your body has the same DNA
sequence but of course not all cells are
the same that's because different cells
use the code in different ways stuff
happens to the genes during development
and through life they're turned on and
off depending on their jobs a cell's
combined set of all these changes is
called
its epigenome the term epigenome
describes changes that affect gene
expression that aren't changes to the
DNA itself the sheet music epigenomic
changes ensure that a heart cell is
different to a brain cell even though
the code is the same new work is helping
to provide a reference of the epigenomic
landscape in lots of different human
cells a fleet of scientists is trying to
examine all these features as a way of
understanding what cells do with their
genetic code and just how flexible it is
and what goes wrong in disease
[Music]
epigenomic changes are chemical tweaks
to DNA and to the proteins that package
our DNA
they don't necessarily affect genes
themselves they affect particular
regions of the code whose job it is to
turn genes on or off one much talked
about change is methylation this is when
a chemical gets added to the DNA and it
Prime's a gene to be turned off another
type of change has more to do with the
arrangement of DNA DNA isn't just in a
big long endless line inside your cells
it's wrapped around proteins called
histones the configuration of these
histone packages and how close together
they sit can affect which genes are read
[Music]
and how many many changes to histone
proteins or to DNA methylation are
normal events in cell growth and
development
when cells age so there are still more
changes to the epigenome some
researchers have spotted an increase in
methylation in older brains for example
the environment - can affect the
epigenome factors like what you eat or
if you smoke or how much you exercise
can also influence the cell through
epigenomic changes some diseases are
linked with epigenomic changes to take
cancer for example where cells replicate
out of control here scientists the rogue
epigenomic changes these changes are
linked to Gene's behaving weirdly genes
being expressed that shouldn't be
expressed or genes shut off that usually
keep cells in check
there are changes to the epigenome in
other disorders to take Alzheimer's one
new study shows that even early in the
condition there can be changes to
methylation in brain cells it's still an
open question whether these changes can
trigger the disease but if they do that
means that drugs that target the
epigenome could one day slow the
progression of Alzheimer's or even help
prevent it finally cells can inherit not
just the DNA the sheet music but the
epigenomic changes too they passed these
on to the next generation of cells just
like a Beethoven symphony a cell's
epigenome is complex and exquisitely
arranged scientists are starting to
understand how that arrangement changes
in different cell types during
development and in disease and it's a
performance that's just beginning
[Music]
produced with exclusive support from
Illumina